[Music]
all right today's question comes from
brian in texas my girlfriend and i have
been together for six
months i recently started working with a
real estate elp to buy my first
house i know this is going to turn into
a huge fight
but i really don't want to bring my
girlfriend into the process
i am the one signing the documents and
i'm the one responsible for the loan
i'd prefer to have the home closed on
first and then tell her about it rather
than having to explain how she does not
get a vote in this process
please let me know how horrible of a
person i am and what the proper way to
handle this would be
what do you think dave ah danger danger
there's something wrong with your
relationship dude that's right
there's something wrong that you don't
want to include her there's something
wrong he thinks it's going to be a fight
there's something
yeah wrong just seems to be messy he
knows something about her
that he's uncomfortable with is that
fair
uh you know what i think huh
i'm i'm reading we're both reading
between the lines because this is all
we've got we've got this paragraph
that's why these are fun that's why you
can just make up whatever we want brian
bryan come on he's a handsome guy yeah
you can just paint him up how big
whatever
he wants yeah so
she is already married in her mind yup
and he ain't nowhere near close and she
has
a say in what he wears where they go
what they eat
what his car needs to be because they're
already married
in her mind that's right and in his mind
we're just sort of dating so you don't
get to pick my house
right yeah i think that's what the
breakdown is
and on the other side of that what was
the thing when our kids were teenagers
they called it
uh d define the relationship
dtr define the relationship yes he has
not done this
no you know why because she's already
defined it for them i know
but they are not on the same wavelength
i'm guessing i have
i know nothing i've been married 39
years i've been out of the market so
long i don't know how this works okay
but
uh oh my gosh that's what it sounds like
it's a red flag to me if someone's been
together six months
and you want to i'm not worried about
hey this is your house she doesn't get a
vote that's all fine
it's that you are thinking about doing
something that's going to bring you this
much stress
this it's this big of an event in your
life and you want to hide it from her
and that tells me that you guys are not
settled in the way y'all
communicate not settled in the way you
guys work together and so you feel like
you have to hide
go around her back because brian you're
being dishonest here
that's the reality now i don't think
you're making a bad decision by saying
you're a horrible person
you're not you're not a horrible person
you might be a drama queen yeah not a
horrible person
um so i think man i'd sit down and say
i'm about to buy a house i've already
picked one out or i'm going to be
picking one out this is my decision this
will be a hard conversation right
because if i'm thinking if i'm dating
someone for six months
and you wouldn't exclude me from this
big of a thing that's a signal to me
right yeah that we're not anytime soon
gonna live in this house together nope
and not only that you don't even want me
to
like have input on the sidewalk right
like this is a big signal
yeah i think i just want to hug brian
i i you know on hug brian okay so one
one of two or three things
if i if i'm right and they're on
different wavelengths on
how close this is to marriage and what
the probability is that's going to end
up in marriage and is she going to live
there
she thinks she's moving in next week he
thinks maybe next decade
maybe maybe or maybe you're just my date
of the week
right um you're not you know so if if
there
i think sir this might be a cue for you
to sit down
and define the relationship perhaps two
of you too
and say and you know you would just say
something like i was thinking about
doing a big decision and i realized that
you were gonna maybe want more input in
that it made me realize we probably
weren't on the same track so i'm not
trying to run you off i like where we
are
but i think you're over here might be
over here and i might be over here
right and let's get aligned on that and
then if you can get aligned on we're
just dating
then it's not offensive for you to buy a
house
and it's never okay the second option is
this chick is overbearing in a control
freak
and you need to run and run
don't lie right yeah yeah just go you
don't get a save because you're just
saying
anything that's right we're not together
anymore right because i don't i'm not
if i if i'm already scared of you and
i'm not married
this is a problem that's the big neon
sign right yeah i hear this all the time
so i go to play golf on saturday or
sunday morning and the uh
golf guy let me go out first because i
was by myself because sharon had the
grain babies
and i had to get like play real fast by
myself
before they woke up and she got to care
for them by ourselves because i
it's tag team event when you have three
grandbabies right so uh in other words i
got to get back to the house or i'm in
trouble and this golf game is not going
to have gone well for my day you follow
me yeah
so i'm standing with these three old
guys and they had me up with them i said
guys
y'all let me go three minutes i'll be
out your way you'll never see me again
i'm gonna play so fast it's blinding and
they go oh yeah we
we understand we're scared of our wives
too
[Laughter]
but it was like four old guys on the
golf tee
old men wife joke right right and
nobody's serious i'm not scared of my
wife of course
but he's scared of her that's right and
his fear is his reaction his fear is
making him become a person who lacks
integrity yeah so don't do that have the
hard conversation you're not a horrible
person
you you don't be a drama queen and don't
be cowardly
and just like dude she's going to find
out anyway
you're going to buy a house it's like oh
yeah that thing up
four months ago i forgot to tell you i
don't think you're gonna have a hard
conversation now or a
hard conversation plus one about how you
lied to her
next month exactly either way have it
dude exact record
that's the whole thing brian
you know what though this is one of
those things we're talking about
marriage and money in the first segment
and how you got you and rachel doing
this money and marriage event this
side's tied together that's right
because now he's making a financial
decision and what is it doing it's
reflecting
it he didn't have a question about how
to do the mortgage he didn't have a
question about whether he could afford
the house
he didn't have a money question in a
relationship question
what was it surfaced by a money decision
right
and then his response to dealing with
that money decision
is making him um it's revealing
it's revealing there you go it's
revealing in him a
a default setting to i'm gonna hide i'm
gonna lie i'm going to
put things in the drawer so she can't
see him right and so it's this
it's this the money reveals the
character and character reveals the
money it all works together
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he's not he's
not a person of lacking integrity no not
at all
all this is is it just signals problems
with the relationship absolutely
there's some kind of problem either
she's an over bearing control freak or
you guys have are on different lanes or
there's a third possible option i don't
know what it is
but those are the two that come to my
mind now listen brian
next week when i'm in here with you dave
and we get a blinds.com question from
an angry girlfriend in texas yeah she
said you guys told my boyfriend to dump
me
that's not what we're saying just have a
hard conversation yeah well
no no i if she's a control freak i said
no
i didn't say that listen if the whole
thing comes down to she has to control
your decisions after six months
you're out this ain't getting better
you're done no this is not going to get
better this is no thank you
or vice versa it doesn't matter whether
it's boyfriend or girlfriend that's
right if he's controlling all of her
decisions
now right miriam run girl it doesn't fix
after that's the wedding it's not gonna
it's not gonna get anything but
worse that's right so there you go
[Laughter]
yeah you know and like money things and
relationship
things do share this in common too that
you and rachel doing that money and
marriage event together
if you extrapolate the decision and
expand it
the results of the decision in other
words you say
i'm going to reach 10 years out from
this decision how does it affect me
and i'm going to make it a hundred times
larger
so these relationship issues in this
email
in this blinds.com question 100 times
bigger
and 10 years from now and and
so the house had nothing to do with it
it was just the revealing point
that says okay you know are you gonna
lie to your wife for ten years about
purchases
right are you gonna because you're
afraid of her reaction are you gonna
hide
or are you gonna be you know are you
gonna live with someone who's gonna try
to control all your decisions
and you can't come to a meeting of the
minds and discuss things and negotiate
through them
you know you know these are things you
reach out past just this decision and
sometimes the answers go
real clear they just open up for you wow
wow wow wow wow you got it brian you can
do it man
you got this i'm glad you do not me you
got this
is the ramsey show